I just want to start and go and go and
go the longest amount of time that I can
draw before the tide kept sit and watch
there anyway my name is Jim Donovan I
draw in the sand to draw on the sand
it's about between a mental game and a
physical they're both equally important
I started drawing in the sand a little
more than 20 years ago
I was walking along the beach one day it
just came to me to use it as a canvas I
just put my finger in the sand and made
a giant fish like it became really
really obsessed with it I left behind
the world wealth of surfing and the job
as a chef and I just took everything
it's a drawing in the sand there's
almost no one in the whole
that did this coming I've drawn and send
around the world Australia Uruguay
Argentina Chile Russia I mean
occasionally a commission but we're also
in places where oh there's an ice
patches town I think all could be
something new the one that was ten miles
in circumference in the desert on dry
lake to kiss world record largest heart
I've walked as much as 30 miles in one
day which means about seven or eight
hours of walking I liked the stick
probably the best because I like to come
down to the beach with nothing
the tools are sitting there on the beach
sticks to choose from
and I'll do my composition do a nice big
drawing and then I'll throw the stick
away I'm down with nothing you leave
with nothing
for me that's most fulfilling choice of
how to do it drawing the sand is the
ultimate of in the moment and I want to
finish when the tide is about to destroy
the time this is gonna change every day
anything I do down there is going to be
gone and every time I'm gonna have a big
huge place to try something new
[Music]
making drawings on land on quite a large
scale is something people we do for
thousands of years
[Music]
I'm slamming back and I make drew-sama
snow he started as a bit of fun but
gradually he's taken over my life a
ballpark estimate of footsteps about
5,000 steps in an hour a big during 2000
every 8 hours work you're looking at
40,000 steps I started doing it as an
easier alternative to hiking at the
mountain when I want as an exercise you
[Music]
starting with a royal a piece of paper
or else a drawing you're from you mind
just treating me like an orienteering
man we're just doing a certain distance
in a certain direction to determine a
distance by Counting paces
it's a very physical exercise its equal
on long days walking in the hills when
you make one of these big drawings I'm
just about the only person in the world
doing anything like it
[Music]
[Music]
this colorful spot has a dark past las
penitas was once a dangerous place with
clashes between rival gangs but the city
government launched and funded a project
called Pachuca paints itself to turn the
community around
[Music]
the painting itself involved
participation from all of the households
[Music]
they painted over 200 houses using 5,000
gallons of paint
[Music]
these individually painted houses
combined to make one beautiful rainbow
design inspired by pachucos nicknamed LA
baya Arosa
for the beautiful breezy City the aim of
the project was to bring a sense of
liveliness and livability
back to the city the Ministry of
planning and evaluation of the city of
Pachuca has noted that the crime rate in
the city has decreased since the mural
was painted
[Music]
with my work I want to create pieces
that engage community together and allow
us to really celebrate something
positive and I love seeing how the
action of crocheting connects people
together
[Music]
I'm Alec I'm an artist and crochet is my
technique I was raised in a communist
Poland with their limited access to any
culture and any public art in 2000 I
came to New York I was 22 I had a
backpack full of dreams and no money and
I was asked to design a costume for a
dancer I couldn't afford buying sewing
machine so I came up with the idea of
using the crochet hook to connect fabric
together and after this was like
explosion I was crocheting gigantic
installation right away crocheting is a
process of making fabric with one
continuous loop I travel around the
world every time I go all my projects
somehow relate to the community I'm
working with our pink house is the
project I created in a Vesta in Sweden
this town accepted a lot of refugees
from Syria and Ukraine
in India and we were crocheting a new
skin for homeless shelter probably most
people know my work because of the wall
street ball micro shell pink camouflage
as they respond to the recent market
crash that happened 2008
currently I'm working on a project olive
across the USA and when I create a mural
in every state that portraits women the
change American history I was creeped
squares or rectangles sometimes and then
when I have enough pieces I crochet
piece by piece together with the help of
the local people who own the power of
this action
I go to this and then I'm just gonna
live and install it people want to be
part of something and I love saying that
hunger that people have to create
something so positive it not just the
image but the power that every single
loop is made by somebody's hand
[Music]
[Music]
there are more in the dairy market avoid
the context not only disability liver
can tangle
[Music]
it's a cafe actual that's Shakuni Obama
focus on joy a 30-month in a cafeteria
food addiction or demurrers so now can
you eat you know adorable in Manoa more
common Amla toasty minimalist this noir
you can lie to steerer hottest a career
in the culinary too crude over it
already
Toyota Motor Show markussi 2013 are
critical
Talia Tunes so they only take some you
know commercial women live in Geneva
[Music]
Tom Watson amino you know cut another in
a non acidic vodka company jiggling
annoying October kangaroo
nyah nyah toriana tiles i Jessica
schemata Mohammad is no chokerino katana
pecan deco purchased a soul Eero
Saarinen you used to say insanely very
nicely chosen a title terminal so
relaxed about our talk show in logroño
showing medicine you don't know me Jesus
Watsuki picked up another you know
uniboob when you're doing it you know
innovator one of the new I don't know
iterated
so a totally scenarios sankarsana Kosovo
sense ambikada ties I know no Sun regime
article on a loose rein Pareto optimal
anushka one homo santen kesshun a
useless Sasha dimitra's keynote event
live-action totally al-maliki no Megan
Ammann Ngongotaha reversal Sasha
continuity from botany systemic renew my
neck my toes kazeno :
[Music]
Cotto's no no ties even a sieve are
porous in baqara yamato naruto Sinanan
akuto to divest tiny Tom Burton you WA
Ta'ala Waterloo new details alternative
[Music]
bar areas high schooi attitude Eva
Marcille corner to Ottoman Allegra
tokima was a great demo in a cottage
Emirati da gamba to number imam Estonia
Nichkhun similarities in a cottage a
monogamist order will come water
insecure wait he would smash teams
[Music]
you